hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to emily is away now this is
another game that got away from me this
is a free-to-play game available on
Steam and it was suggested a long time
ago I just didn't have the chance to
play it and it got forgotten I'm sorry
but I'm here playing it now so my screen
name is Mark EMU 69 Markheim uber 6
that's good enough
mark BAM my buddy icon is that blink-182
hoo boy Lord of the Rings Harry Potter
oh the ring I like that one okay ex
Jules Bobby ooh hi
man it's been so long since I used
America instant mess hey IM is that what
it is even called american instant
messenger howdy
that sounds like me oh that's not what i
Emily
howdy oh that familiar sound oh geez
before everyone happened text messaging
I like your new buddy I can that movie
is so scary what's up ah ah talking to
you super important what are you up to
[Music]
Lowell well no [ __ ] I'm just listening
to music uh do you like Coldplay ah I'm
not really a big fan of music in general
I know one album of theirs so yeah
totally totally their last album was
really good I don't know which one that
was Emily will remember that oh [ __ ]
it really was I'm so glad you like them
they're my favorite their lyrics are in
my info oh can I can I go to your info
we live in a beautiful world yeah we do
yeah we do oh I did not know that was
that always there or was that just there
now let's see are you going to Travis's
party tonight let's see depends on if
you're going yeah wait ah what no what
was what I could do the smiley face
I'll give you that law well I am so you
should go and see it's crazy that we're
already having into school parties wait
who is that Jules
err SSH is keeping distance rat Darko
the dreams in which I'm dying are the
best I've ever had man why does everyone
have musical lyrics is that what people
add in their profiles back then not me
these numbers mean is this important
Lord Lord minion 777 Wow
Lord minion 777 is here huh I like Lord
minion 777 right there I can't wait for
school to be over and start my life as a
youtuber button same here I'm so over
this school year I see like you know
Brad from our math class
he won't stop messaging me right now uh
Brad Darko what's he saying that he
wants to talk or something I'm not
really paying attention oh man just one
more month to graduation we're so old
I'm so excited for college oh yes did
you pick a school yet it's gonna be so
rad man I mean lady yeah I didn't get
accepted into my read school so I'm just
going good one of the others but that's
okay anything's better than high school
where you gonna go an engineering school
yeah I'm not sure what kind of
engineering I want to do but I'm sure
I'll figure it out that's pretty much a
weird it story in my life you chose to
attend an engineering school that's
awesome you've always been super smart
I'm sure you'll do really well oh this
is so weird
even though we're going to different
schools do you promise you'll be there
for me let's see oh absolutely
nothing could ever keep me from talking
to you you're my
one you're one of my bit oh oh Emily
will remember that you're one of mine
too
you always will be mark oh wow it's
getting late I hope Julie gets here soon
so we can head to the party are you
leaving soon yeah soon as Julie gets
here then we're both headed to traps
party if you're coming - you should
probably leave soon will I see you there
definitely I'm so going to this red
party chose to attend the party what
that's so cool
I'm going to go get ready there's so
many choices oh that's cool
see you soon see later late later keep
it cash keep it nice and cash in this
conversation later oh I got an
achievement just at 2002
[Music]
oh cool
oh hell yeah Oh the matrix this is still
is it too early for that
I do like Nemo ooh I'm gonna go and this
is when the later Matrix movies were I'm
gonna go Nemo I'm full meme em again oh
Emily Emily hello I like your new icon
Finding Nemo is the Beast has it shaken
yeah I'm so cash ha it's shaking I guess
I'm just doing some homework and
listening to music to uh you know play
video games I do all day every day
Sixto Coldplay huh Snow Patrol they just
came out with a new album final strive
you heard of it have I it's way
something about car chasing cars
something something like that you always
know the best music oh geez um let me
just look up which one of these is
actually a Snow Patrol song yeah that's
one run runs run yeah hell yeah I really
like yeah nailed it nailed it Oh so how
you like an engineering school orange
it's so boring I feel like I haven't
learned anything so far ah you're too
smart for your own good I'm struggling
with some classes right now got any
plans tonight
see whoo God my friend Mac throwing a
massive ass party oh hell yeah hell yeah
we're gonna have a matter raging kegger
don't get too drunk
no no promises to try my best I guess
was this personal profile my heart is
bursting is in your perfect eyes as blue
as oceans as pure skies oh oh that's a
murli's profile Oh depends on how crazy
the party gets do you have plans tonight
nope brad has band practice so I'm just
hanging out in my room do I do
I know Brad rad he's my boyfriend do you
remember him from high school we've been
dating for a couple months now
oh good I'm happy for you yeah what yeah
whatever there's probably plenty of
Brad's at this house party I'm going to
I might make out with a few Brad's uh
I'm happy for you how did you two get
together anyway well remember that grad
party we went to last year while I was
away Brad sent me a ton of messages
about how he felt at first I thought he
was really weird but after a while I
realized it was kind of brave we started
talking again over the summer and
realized we were going to the same
school once we got here which Conn hit
it off what's he like is this the same
Brad that was really creepy well he's
smart and funny and he understands me
I'm smart and funny and understanding
sometimes he can be a jerk but when it's
good it's really good is he ever mean to
you hmm
getting into this was weird he can get
pretty nasty when we argue but that's it
we're both very stubborn people so we go
back and forth a lot but like I said
when things are good they're really good
I don't want to be bold and claim that
it's a bad relationship
I guess it's normal man I feel like a
young teenager because I have a funny
feeling that in this circumstance the
person that I'm enacting is kind of
having a crush on little Emily over
there so but saying you deserve better
isn't exactly something nice to say when
someone says as good as good so I guess
yeah I guess as normal as long as you're
okay I am we just get loud when we argue
is all oh this poor person oh oh
ah the good old teenage years I'm gonna
be bald here I wouldn't treat you like
that
what why No come on that's not what I
said that's not what I would have said
all right Emily will remember that
oh geez oh geez listen I think we're
fine I don't want to talk about any more
you should you should break up with him
oh jeez what a type what I meant to say
when I come out a little better but I am
happy I promise
oh wow it's getting late you need to go
to that party don't you I can stay no
that's that's pitifully pathetic yeah
she doesn't want to talk about anymore
if there's were me I would I would go
and leave it where it was nothing you
can do about it you're in different
schools I mean what could you do in the
term of this game and the person what he
wants
oh and what would I do what would I do
well this is about me this is about what
I would do and I'd leave it where it was
I mean I'd leave it where it was she's
happy I should be happy for her so I
should go yeah I should go catch you
around the Riverbend okay late later
later Gator emily is away Oh emily is
away okay
2004 sophomore are we gonna go through
the whole entirety of college Oh
incredible zinc rattles you looted oh
Emily up she's an amused fade yo yo what
up what up what up what were ah not much
how's life I feel like we haven't talked
in a while it's good it's good how's
yours cake plane lonely hmm that's fine
gonna aint plans this weekend where's
buddy
whoa go to Sochi her warehouse party
with my friend Emma oh I didn't know
about this we upgrade from the house
party to a kegger there weren't any
Brad's at this party produces a lot of
Emma's that sounds like fun
who's Emma a girl I like yeah I'm moving
on to the girl that I have
a thing for ya
oh wow I don't think I've heard you talk
about her before I bet this guy better
not be making Emma how did you two meet
Mike who else Mike uh at that boner hell
yeah
at some party I think I don't really
remember yeah I was so blasted drunk
yeah so what's she like she's she god
she's she's kind
oh she's just a sweetheart oh she's just
a sweetheart Wow mark sounds like things
are going really well that's just so
great the avenue plans his weekend well
me and Brad were supposed to go see a
show but that's not having oh we could
have been to the same Oh new if I'd have
said show but maybe I would have said I
was still going with Emma that probably
would have been in sisli
I'm sorry I'm so sorry oh Emily I'm so
sorry how are you I'm okay it's just
been really weird since me and him had
the same group of friends so things are
messy mm-hmm
I just feel really alone you know I'm
here for you well you know I'm here for
you
I know and thank you for that I just
feel really abandoned why did you break
up
you chose ask about the break-up uh I
guess I guess we just kind of grew apart
I feel like Brad changed it a lot over
the summer and things were just
different when we got back oh man now
I'm starting to cry there's no point in
telling anyone hey hey don't cry hey
that thing you're doing it's stupid and
dumb and don't do that
I just just commiserate I guess I am his
lost you're amazing you're you're an
amazing person also amazing same thing I
guess Thanks
I'm sorry for just being such a mess
I'll always be here for you it's okay
I'm I'll always be here for you nice to
be able to talk about this mm-hmm I
haven't really had the chance to vent
yet I know you'd do the same for me
I want to ask you something but I'm
afraid you'll hate me after uh promise
me you
hate me I could never hate you never a
Travis's party senior year remember how
we got bored and went for that walk whoo
we stopped at that playground for a bit
and we just laid there and looked at the
Stars mm-hmm well why didn't you kiss me
I didn't that wasn't a multiple choice
option Emily if I'd have done that you
better believe your butt I would have
been kissing you not your butt but you
uh-oh screw things up but his a buddy
was real yeah I don't know just means
that I was obviously think about it but
I was too coward III didn't know you
felt that way honestly and truly I
didn't know you felt that no I didn't
know you didn't tell me I didn't tell
you I've just always wondered how things
would be if you did why not good
considering we were at different schools
I don't know it's kind of stupid I guess
let's see you should have told me true
you should have told me but I mean it
wouldn't have mattered because we're at
different schools it would been
impossible to be together like in that
circuit on impossible but I mean for a
start of a relationship new new new new
I mean I honestly don't wish I would
have kissed you but right what would I
do if if she was coming at me asking me
why I didn't kiss her it's not a very
nice thing to go like well you should
have told me
David baby dabei it would have been it
probably better to say that like admit
feelings now and then I wish I'd kissed
you I wish I had I wish I had I'll say
it I'll say it out loud yeah I have an
idea
maybe I could come visit this weekend
whoa I could really use some time away
from this school how far away and we
always said we would visit each other
what do you think as long as it's just
as friends uh where's where's good old
no there's Brad
mistakes and regrets I walk this empty
street on the Boulevard of broken dreams
true drummer wanted okay sure
please please come visit please come
visit I would love to see you
considering I have no idea who the hell
am I is but we'll see where things go
what about your plans with some EMA I
can ditch her
that sounds really mean I'll make up
some excuse that's just lying I'll talk
to her about it well I don't know if
that's the right thing I don't know how
you're gonna talk to her about it if
you're like I don't know what you mean
by when you say you'll talk to her about
it are you gonna go to Emma and be like
hey I like this girl Emily we can't be a
thing sorry that's what it would that's
all it would take
that's all it would take for an adult to
be a nerd dome I'm gonna trust you on
this one I'm trusting you that that's
what you mean when you say I'll talk to
her about it I'm assuming that that's
the adult choice and it means what I
think it means although I could see how
it would go another way but I don't
think making up an excuse or ditching
her would be a good idea so I'm gonna
open it I'll talk to her about it okay I
just don't want to mess things up
well I'm good what do you want to do
this weekend goes to buddies nah let's
go some stuff around campus just
whatever around campus yes Deborah okay
sounds good to me should I bring in my
alcohol but yeah oh yeah oh yeah dear
departed owner okay I'm in so excited to
finally come visit oh [ __ ] I actually
have to run I'll see you this weekend of
course of course babe babe I II Chapter
four it's another full year later
oh okay
ah I did like V for Vendetta a lot
there's a gorilla gang go V oh go V
oh go V hi Everly hey yo yo what up I
know it's been a while since we last
talked why is that the thing that that
is a Death Cab for Cutie I don't want
your help
way down to bottom love is watching
someone dies who's gonna watch you die
whoo
I said let's see that's okay
I've just been going through a lot
lately everything okay
yeah everything is fine well that
doesn't sound like everything's fine so
listen I was hoping we could talk about
things of course what's up
would you choose not to talk with Emily
I don't know what the choices are if you
don't I just feel like things are weird
between us have you felt that too
I don't think so but then again I've
been gone in hibernation for like a full
year I don't think so I think it's
because of last year things have been
weird since I came to visit mark please
be honest with me did you plan that we
would hook up what how could I have plan
that what I did once what do you mean do
you plan you can't what I thought it was
possible
hmm that's just what in retrospect it
all just seems so planned out I mean we
hung out with your friends around campus
then we go back to your dorm to drink
did you want us to get really drunk I
just wanted it
you wanted to hook oh I don't know this
is getting Ince's messes messy territory
I know me too
I just I don't know did I do something
wrong
you chose to ask about yourself oh
that's not what I touched now when I
thought those Todd Jesus just a lot
happened really quickly it just made me
feel differently in a bad way
[Music]
no not bad just different I don't know
will we ever be the same
oh god no what kind of questions are
these to ask are we still friends are we
still friends
yeah at least I think so I'm sorry
things are just really weird for me
right now but thank you for talking to
me about it
we can talk anytime any old time exactly
a year from now it's good
College is flying by that doesn't sound
good at all so how's your friend uh Mike
who's Mike we're exciting Mike
entrepreneur Club the Innovation Center
and all I want to hear is a message beep
my name who I don't know he's not really
my friend anymore yeah it sucks when
people change
what's the suit put me about your other
friend Emma haven't seen her in a while
after you know I itch stir is she just a
friend or she's just a friend okay
it's weird cuz I'm making up reality as
we're going along sorry I don't think I
can do this right now
what do you mean talking right now is
just kind of hard I've got to go soon
anyways we'll talk again later
of course okay of course soon in another
year
oh one more year senior year of college
partay oh boy
Oh 300 I wasn't a 300 stick yeah that's
probably me Emily
howdy howdy howdy howdy howdy howdy
hey hey how's it shaking it's good how
are you let me check your profile hard
to argue when you want something
sensible my tongue miss miss a digging
my own grave we'll walk from this dark
room for the last time the passages that
things could be better mix okay sorry to
hear that have you have you been
everything's been really good Oh
everything's really good what's new in
your life not a lot really just
finishing up college oh I don't know if
you knew me and Brad got together Oh
even after that awful breakup well it
was so awful because we cared for each
other so much how's your friend Emma
doing well well she started dating Mike
so now I barely see her oh hi I have
other friends it's okay I have other
friends
one one other friend well college is
almost over anyway can you believe we're
almost adults I can't judging by this
conversation we've had over the few
years
nope it's definitely doesn't feel like
it's been four years high school was
yeah it was I'd rather not think about
the past though well okay I'm just tired
of reliving memories so all set for
graduation I think so I still have to
order my gown and stuff what are you
doing the summer just hang out here with
Brad and try to find a job
can we no we can't no don't talk about
things No
we shouldn't talk about things mmm she
doesn't want to talk about things let's
talk about things oh oh
not really I just been working could I
see you this summer oh there's gonna be
a cowardly up there we go are you doing
homework BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR you had
to sell stuff before do you ever miss
things our classes oh boy
oh the smallest of small talks we're
good same old same old
do you miss me oh geez Judy he's
listening to old stuff will we ever be
little hey oh boy oh boy oh boy is this
it for us Oh Oh how's the weather
whoa okay I gotta go okay I think I've
got to go goodbye okay okay bye whoo Oh
[Music]
oh that's the end Oh God oh damn it holy
[ __ ]
whoo boy that is that is whew that is a
thing that was cool that was really cool
an interesting experience because my
problem not with the game but with the
dialogue in there was that it didn't say
what he meant
if he just said what I told them to said
actually you know I take that back I
don't know if there's any way that you
could have gone and made that work out
okay I mean you probably could had a
better outcome where you would have been
better friends towards the end of that
except and not quite such dissonant
partners or partners dissonant people
you know it's very interesting because
it was it was one of those things where
the effort was made and it went well but
all the option
happened behind the scenes you know to
say and those could have changed the
outcome and yet I wonder like maybe if I
told her not to bring booze if things
would have been okay or maybe if I did
that it would have been in a different
way anyways so I don't really know but I
could play through this again but I
don't feel like playing through the
entire game again for that so we shall
see what happens when what happens I
might look up to see if there are now
you know what I'll look it up now okay
alright I looked it up I'm not sure how
serious this is but just from one I
didn't want to spoil too much just in
case it were but from what they were
talking about people tried over and over
and over again and they you know they
they couldn't get any different any more
from what they did and I think that's
exactly what I was talking about the
situation that it is is kind of very
difficult for people to experience I
wonder if the developer of this game
experiences for themselves because
really interesting that the way things
play out things can happen but in the
end the distance and you can't control
what someone does on their own with the
other people in their lives you know all
that wrapping together makes a really
interesting dynamic and the but the
inevitability of it is really cool so I
don't know if there's no other endings
but from what I saw it doesn't seem like
there are very many other endings and it
was kind of like perfect that emily is
away is the name of the game and then at
the end of it Markham uber six is away
so either way that is great I'm sorry it
took me so long to play this game but
that was really cool so let me know what
you thought down the comments below let
me know if I've assumed anything wrong
in the comments below as well and thank
you again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]